hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning iot full course but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we will begin with a quick crash
course on iot where we will learn what
exactly is iot and the fundamental
concepts of internet of things followed
by the crash course on iot we will learn
what is arduino once we understand what
exactly is arduino we will dive into the
raspberry pi once we are done with the
fundamentals and technical concepts of
arduino and raspberry pi we will discuss
the critical differences between the
both
so once having a better understanding of
what are raspberry pi and or renault and
their critical differences between each
of them we will try to develop some
projects based on both arduino and
raspberry pi once we have the best
understanding of arduino and raspberry
pi we will dive deep into raspberry pi
zero once we are done with the raspberry
pi zero we will dive into the latest
version of raspberry pi that is
raspberry pi 4. so these are the agenda
pointers that we will be discussing
today hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now over to our training experts
until recently access to the internet
was limited via devices like the desktop
tablet or smartphone
but now with the internet of things aka
iot practically all appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely
it is a system of interconnected devices
that transfer data
over a wireless network without any
human intervention
so hey everyone in this video we help
you understand what iot is and how it is
impacting our day-to-day life
we will also understand the iot
architecture and look at the new
trending iot projects for 2021
but before that if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
i'm sure you're excited to learn so
let's dive right in
imagine you're at work and realize that
you might not have turned off the air
conditioner while leaving your house
instead of traveling all the way back
home what if you could use your
smartphone to know the status of your ac
and perhaps even turn it off
wouldn't that be amazing
well yes
and this can be achieved with the help
of the internet of things
until recently access to the internet
was limited via devices like the desktop
tablet or smartphone but now with iot
practically all appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely iot is shaping the way we live
our lives it helps us get a better
insight into the working of things
around us
so what exactly is the internet of
things
iot is a system of interrelated devices
connected to the internet to transfer
and receive data from one to the other a
smart home is the best example of iot
home appliances like the ac doorbell
thermostats smoke detectors water
heaters and security alarms can be
interconnected to share data with the
user over a mobile application
the user can now get detailed insight
into the working of the devices around
him
think about it until recently the
internet helped people connect and
interact with each other but now
inanimate objects or things have the
ability to sense the surroundings to
interact and collaborate with one
another
for example
in the morning when your alarm goes off
the iot system can open the window
blinds turn on the coffee pot for you
and even turn on the water heater
although all of this is fascinating
there's a lot that goes on in the
background to ensure seamless
functioning from effective communication
between devices to accurate processing
of the data received a lot of components
are involved
in the context of iot devices hardware
can be classified into general devices
and sensing devices the general devices
are the main components of the data hub
and information exchange
they are connected either by wired or
wireless interfaces
home appliances are a classic example of
such devices
the sensing devices on the other hand
include sensors and actuators they
measure the temperature humidity light
intensity and other parameters
these iot devices are connected to the
network with the help of gateways
these gateways or processing nodes
process the information collected from
the sensors and transfer it to the cloud
the cloud acts as both the storage and
processing unit actions are performed on
the collected data for further learning
and inferences
wired and wireless interfaces like wi-fi
bluetooth zigbee gsms and so on are used
to provide connectivity to ensure its
ubiquity applications need to support a
diverse set of devices and communication
protocols from tiny sensors capable of
sensing and reporting the desired factor
to powerful back-end servers that are
utilized for data analysis and knowledge
extraction
to help you understand it's working
let's take a simple scenario
let's suppose you want to water your
garden every time the moisture level in
the soil drops
instead of doing it manually you could
automate it using iot
the sensors and actuators installed
gauge the soil for its moisture this
information is sent to the iot gateway
with the help of communication protocols
like mqtt or http the gateway
significantly aggregates data and feeds
it to the cloud with the help of wi-fi
lan
once the moisture level drops the system
is immediately triggered and the
sprinklers are turned on however with
the information stored in the cloud a
detailed analysis like the time of the
day the sprinkler was turned on the rate
at which the moisture in the soil
reduces and so on can be done and the
report could be sent over to you on your
smartphone over an app
with the improved response monitoring
and analytical capabilities iot is being
adopted in almost all industries and
domains opening doors to endless
applications
today iot is being used extensively to
lessen the burden on humans to name a
few iot is deployed for smart homes
wearables watches and bracelets smart
cars
smart farming smart retail smart grids
smart city and smart health care
with such a wide spectrum of
applications the future of i.t looks
more promising than ever before
in 2018 there were about 23 billion
connected devices which was more than
double the world population
according to experts there will be over
80 billion devices by 2025. iot is a
vision to connect all devices with the
power of the internet always learning
and always growing
now that you have a picture of what iot
is here's a simple question for you
which of the following technologies is
not used as an interface for a network
one wi-fi
2. ethernet
3.
zigbee
4. vpn
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
the integration of iot with other
technologies like cloud computing
machine learning and artificial
intelligence is paving the way for many
new and exciting innovations
and that is the internet of things for
you in short
the first wave of the internet
revolution came in with the growth of
personal computers and in the second
wave the internet came right onto our
palms that is with the advent of mobile
devices and here we are living the third
wave where all electronic devices are
almost already connected to the internet
or will be in the near future
yes the internet of things will bring
about the next industrial revolution and
will drastically transform the way we
live and experience technology today
quite possibly the internet of things
will be as disruptive as the internet
itself particularly when combined with
big data and predictive analytics
but what exactly is iot the concept
behind iot is about connecting just
about everything to the internet in real
time which directly improves our quality
of life and experiences
for instance how are you watching this
video right now on a pc a mobile or a
tablet well whichever device you're
using is definitely connected to the
internet and that means you're already
using an iot device
sensors are becoming the end points of
iot networks wondering what exactly a
sensor is
these sensors collect an increasing
amount of context aware data and
information such as location images
weather conditions and inject them into
networks actuators and applications in
real time
big data analytics and predictions have
become apparent synonymous helping
perform and execute tasks seamlessly
with minimal to zero errors
are you ready to admit a major
breakthrough life in the present is
great but the future looks like it could
be way more exciting how we may ask
since there are billions of physical
devices around the world that are now
connected to the internet collecting and
sharing data in real time terabytes of
data are going to become better bytes
which represents 1000 terabytes each
there is going to be a shift from
wideband networks to narrowband networks
for better range
and you'll also soon witness the
communication system transcend from 4g
to 5g wireless communications
[Music]
iot will definitely be the paradigm
shift of effective multitasking with
massive applications
now let's have a look at the future with
iot environment
imagine you're driving your smart car to
work and you're quite late don't you
worry because your car can now provide
the shortest route with less congestion
not only that the integrated sensors in
the car alerts you about mechanical
assistance you also have the access to
automatic temperature control and not to
forget in case you're tired or wary the
car becomes self-driven since it comes
with an accident prevention system
as you're driving you see the smart
farms through your window farmers are
happier thanks to iot which helped them
with better heat and provided more
efficiency than ever
you might wonder how with the help of
systems like autonomous self-driving
tractors adaptive irrigation systems
soil health monitoring and animal
welfare monitoring systems this is
possible
you also see smart factories which use
iiot that is industrial internet of
things with the help of analytics and
automation systems iiot helps in
tracking goods in real time inventory
management automated delivery system and
much more now you're returning home from
office your car can park itself
automatically your fingerprint voice or
even your smartphone is enough to
control all home appliances from lights
to television and your door to what it
taps too are you excited to experience
this smart future which is not far away
of course you should be
the applications of iot will be seen in
every industry across sectors be it
education healthcare manufacturing
automotive you name it iot is definitely
going to have a role to play in each one
of them
possibly the fourth way will be the
internet of everything or ioe which
would encompass all physical things
processes data and people through
wearables and surgically implanted
sensors unlike iot which focuses only on
physical devices
change is the only constant and the
world will never be the same with the
growth of ubiquitous connectivity and
iot is sure to change the way billions
of people live their lives today why to
internet of things
as a learner you should learn iot
as it provides better scope for future
data scientists as well as provides for
promising career opportunities
you can also build and manage your own
iot for your home as a company executive
you should learn iot because it will
help you measure everything in the
business you also get real-time metrics
actionable data and better connectivity
across industries
after completing this course you should
be able to explain the concept of
internet of things comprehensive
describe hardware software and other
connectivity building blocks of iot
describe design considerations
pertaining architecture
framework and interoperability
explain the security considerations with
iot pertaining to vulnerabilities
explain industry 4.0 internet to
everything and social iot
and finally describe iot framework in
enterprises
in the context of iot devices hardware
can be divided into two categories
general devices and sensing devices
the general devices do the embedded
processing and connectivity for the
platforms they are connected either by
wired network or wireless interfaces
they are the main component for data
collection and information processing
the current home appliances are classic
example of such devices that are
controlled by a sensor these sensors
help solve common problems
apart from sensors actuators are another
important device in iot that perform
similar functions with different
capabilities they work as interface
between sensors that machines and
collect various information like
humidity and light intensity
this information is computed using the
edge layer which typically sits between
the cloud and the sensor they are the
layers that store the intermittent
transfer of information
finally the backend server of the cloud
processes this information
both the sensors and actuators are the
chief components of iot the sensors
measure temperature humidity light
intensity and other key parameters of
home environment
the second most crucial aspect of iot is
device management platforms or dmps
the dmvs as they are shortly called are
the platforms through which these assets
interact with the software layer through
network gateways dmps come with various
functionalities which include firmware
upgrades security patching and reporting
of metrics they also help develop alert
mechanism the industrial equipment with
more open source os like arduino overall
it is an important aspect of the
management of the device penetration
connectivity blocks connectivity blocks
collectively it's considered as the
backbone of an iot setup
there are various connectivity layers
like usb can protocols and modbus
the next generation protocols of wi-fi
are lora and zigbee they can interface
with any application or modules a small
device embedded in an object
the entire landscape is called gateway
architecture
various ports are
232.485 from usb that come with gateway
architecture
the device interface is important for
the data transfer and enables digital
transformation with third-party
applications and systems
communication protocols and standards
let us try to understand the various
communication protocols available to set
up an iot
the first is the satellite this enables
the cell phone communication through an
antenna situated within 10 to 15 miles
they have a stable and universal
connection
the second is the protocol is the wi-fi
and is based on five gigahertz
frequencies
it provides internet access within a
certain range and are an affordable
option
it has well protected protocols
the third is the radio frequency
it is the easiest form of communication
a few examples are zigbee and z-wave
which use low-power rf radio
it consumes low energy which is very
advantageous
is relatively simple to configure
the fourth in this list is rfid it uses
wireless electromagnetic fields to
identify sensors and objects
good thing about it is that it does not
require power
the fifth is bluetooth which is useful
for short term and short distance data
exchange
is present in every smartphone and has
sensors
the final one is near-field
communication or nfc it uses
electromagnetic induction and loop
antennas
it comes with encryption has low speed
communication and is used for short
range data exchange
future of iot connectivity
iot connectivity is the future the
launch of new technologies like 5g
the 5g with low latency and higher
throughput will increase the penetration
of iot
5g cellular technology is supported by
the network for virtualization
even for the common use case such as for
t vendor real-time predictive analytics
can be available
so
overall the delivery time is reduced
with iot
5g and iot are embedded technologies
both can be sliced and diced for
predictive analytics and real-time
business decisions
5g will help devices connect through a
network with high speed bandwidth
iot device architecture
there are four layers in the device
architecture
the base layer consists of iot devices
this includes all the components like
sensors with the ability to sense
compute and connect other devices
let's move on to the second layer which
is the iot gateway or aggregation layer
this layer significantly aggregates data
from various sensors these two layers
form the definition engine and they set
the rules for data aggregation next
layer is based on cloud is called
processing engine or event processing
layer it has numerous algorithms and
data processing elements that are
ultimately displayed on a dashboard
this layer basically processes the data
obtained from the sensor layer
the last layer is called the application
layer or api management layer it acts as
an interface between third-party
application and infrastructure the
entire landscape is supported by device
managers and identity and access
managers
which are useful for security of the
architecture
many individuals and organizations have
contributed to create and set the
standard it covers the entire network
and endpoint systems it brings a
structural approach with security
controls in place it provides a
demarcation based on its uses for
enterprise to build iot products this
standard has 85 detailed recommendations
and a structured approach that can fit
into any iot ecosystem it has a flexible
framework addressing the diversity of
the technology aligned to the regulation
it also has risk modeling capabilities
for any organization to choose from
including endpoint ecosystems the
standard is very flexible and comes with
the inbuilt risk assessments for any
organization to adapt overall it is an
interesting standard and easy to get
trained at iot security best practices
there are many best practices in iot
security let's look at some best
practices pertaining to iot hardware
first of all the hardware should be
tamper-proof
they should have undergone dynamic
testing with specific data protection
algorithms and should be updated on
firmware and patches
the network components must be authentic
with encryption kernel controls and
division of networks into segments other
security measures include privacy
protection for sensitive information and
other regulations like safe harbor
statements there are many value drivers
to help the internet of everything
key drivers are employee productivity
supply and logistics
customer experiences
innovation and time to market asset
utilization all the factors are tightly
linked to generate a new revenue gains
for any enterprise
time to market and innovation
this will help with the competitive
index
of the organization
he'll help discover mvp to reduce the
cost of building and bring improvement
in customer experience
asset utilization is the form of digital
physical and even smart assets the asset
discovery is the requirement for the
establishment of the iot ecosystem
supply chain is also a key value driver
and assesses the requirement of internet
of everything
in addition to the drivers there are
significant elements the elements stand
in four buckets the first is data which
encapsulates sending and analyzing data
the second bucket is the people
who are always connected and have
contextual subject mapping with the
real-time world for decision making
the third bucket is the things which
link people to machine with endpoints
ivf addresses and sensors
the last bucket is machined to data
which talks with a business value and
action iteration
essentially building simple models to
achieve corporate results
internet of everything growth engine the
internet of everything comes with a
growth engine for any organization it
includes people for the most valuable
resources
the process of making the right effort
for things that includes the physical
devices other objects and the data taken
from sensors to make actionable insights
for decision making is important
people
process
things and data are the growth engine
elements it gives the company an edge in
the digital transformation world
with data privacy and transparency
mechanism it is important for every
organization to follow internet ethics
and compliance
iot and fleet management
let's discuss some use cases of iot
the fleet management is a classic
example of iot in application in this
domain iot is mainly used to track
vehicles from one point to another
using iot technology the entire fleet
can be monitored with the support of
rfid chips embedded within every car in
the fleet
the same rfid can also be used to track
products such as consumer goods
electronics and food items
you can get real-time
information on the routes that the fleet
takes there are obd devices that can be
used to track vehicles behavior and
performance including fuel consumption
and mileage
this can reduce the total cost and
provide greater return on investment
according to a recent study the act will
increase to 8.28 billion dollars by
2021. sensor's linked artificial
intelligence helped the bankers track
all the activities in the back end
the advancements of mobile phones and
digital assistants along with 5g
connectivity makes customer experience
seamless
first and foremost it is data data is
the new oil
financial institutions have structured
and unstructured data of the customers
they can slice and dice the data for
profiling segmentation product launches
and digital services enablement
the data can create a large economic
drive and give rise to new business
models like nfc banking digital
assistance banking and social media
banking
with this transformation internet of
things provides competitive advantage to
the banking insurance and financial
services
while the end goal remains to help
customers save money and give a bundle
offer
let's understand how iot revolutionizes
various industries
with the advent of the internet of
things there are many industries
experiencing digital transformation
such as financial services
care manufacturing
communications
energy
retail and transportation
user infrastructure and large-scale
applications analytics with real-time
dashboards and iot support allows
informed decision making for businesses
this also means that iot is introducing
a new revenue model for enterprises
around the world
learning objectives by the end of this
lesson you will be able to
buy architecture and frameworks
describe the iot interoperability
and its design considerations and
discuss industry aligned use cases
iot device architecture
there are four layer texture the base
layer consists of iot devices
this includes all the components
like sound to sense compute and connect
other devices
let's move on to the second layer which
which is the iot gateway or aggregation
line efficiently aggregates data from
various to set the rule for data
variations layers based on cloud is
called processing engine or event
processing layer
it has numerous algorithms and data
processing elements that are ultimately
displayed on a dashboard
this is the data obtained from sensor
layer the last layer is called the
application layer or appli layers
between third part and infrastructure
the entire landscape is supported by
device managers and identity and access
managers
which are useful for architecture
iot reference architecture
next let's learn about the various
layers in iot rf